yo what does if everybody mad Luigi here
and if you're watching this video that
means you want to get fallout 4 early
and if you're not a employee of Game
Stop or Steam and you don't have easy
access to getting get a copies of the
game before it releases on November 10th
then you will want to hear some of the
things I've say in this video some
methods of getting a game before it's
supposed release date such as November
10th for fallout 4 so first thing I'm
gonna go over is getting a physical copy
early now
the best way to do this go to a
mom-and-pop shop so this is a local
store it's not a franchise like game
stuff or Target and it's a small local
run locally and so they have a probably
smaller supply of things but chances are
they're not going to be as strict with
releasing the games on a specific date
one because they might not be with as
well acquainted with it and two because
if they sell it on the release date then
they're not they're gonna get beat out
by gamestop so Game Stop will definitely
be able to sell a lot more of the game
on the release date so if they release
it earlier they can get some profits
that they wouldn't otherwise get so mom
pop shop is the best way to get a game
early you can also go for a shipping
service that ships out games or anything
else early I know some Amazon Prime
people had the their estimates of when
thought for should get to them they had
it as before November 10th that's an
option and lastly it's an unknowable
person working at a larger retailer or
distributor so like Walmart or Target or
Best Buy if you find someone that isn't
too well acquainted with games and say
hey I was looking for fallout 4 and I
didn't see it around I think it's
supposed to be out you guys you might
have in the back they might go back
check if they have it and they're not
too keen on that it's supposed to be
released only on a specific date
November 10th for this case then they
might give you the game and you might
get early however I think this is the
least likely way of doing it so I see
that your best bet is a mom-and-pop shop
selling it early and then the shipping
service and then the knowledgeable
person or your chances of getting it now
onto digital I want to say for digital
for consoles I'm not sure but for Steam
if you're gonna do the way I'm about to
tell you it is violating the ste steams
Terms of Service and
account can get bands like take
completely taken away from you and all
your games taking away from you if you
do this so be warned and you're only
gonna get 15 hours earlier to play the
game so the method you're gonna want to
use is getting a VPN now a VPN is a
virtual private network if you don't
know a lot about it you can look it up
but it's basically secures and protects
your the privacy of your internet usage
and you have to get a VPN has an IP
address setup on Australia these the
game releases by timezone and Australia
is the first time zone or straily has
the first time zone in which the game is
gonna be released so you get an IP
that's in Australia your game steam or
your console thinks that you're in
Australia and it releases the preloaded
game now once you do this you're going
to want to go into offline mode since
otherwise if the VPN goes down or you
start playing on not on off the VPN then
your game and steam is gonna realize
that you're not in a place that the game
is supposed to be able to run and they
might kick you out or they might stop
letting you play so go offline when you
do this I will reiterate that to do this
at your own risk
I am NOT a bearer of any responsibility
if your account gets terminated for
doing this because your account on Steam
can you terminate it I don't know about
consoles so if you're gonna want to get
digital copy then get a VPN and get a
little early access because this game
will this game is as I said it's about
15 hours earlier release then North
America North America gets the game all
at once in one same time even though we
have many time zones so the first time
zone of Australia will get it before 15
hours earlier than North America so
that's the video if you guys have
enjoyed this if you have make sure you
check out my channel I'm gonna be
releasing more fallout 4 contents in the
upcoming days and weeks so if you're
looking forward to that keep an eye on
my channel thank you for watching and
peace out